well this you have to see Herschel
Walker did what was probably not a good
idea he held the press conference to
talk about this Scandal that has
surfaced as he is Accused by one of the
mothers of one of his children of urging
her and subsequently paying for her to
get an abortion despite claiming to be
completely against abortion claiming
that abortion is murder claiming that he
is against any exceptions for abortion
Health life of the mother or incest rape
all these different things and this one
was essentially an abortion of
convenience according to the mother who
said he said it wasn't the right time
for him to be having a baby he decided
to hold a press conference and I have to
tell you this is the most disastrous
press conference I can remember this is
as bad as any Trump press conference and
I remember when Trump talked about
injecting bleach okay
Herschel Walker can barely speak and so
when you put him in front of reporters
who are going to ask questions it's
bound to be a disaster and it was
I don't even know where to start
Herschel Walker was asked
have you now that it has been identified
that the woman making the claim about
the abortion is one of the mothers of
your children
that's a known number of people have you
reached out to one of the mothers to ask
them hey are you the one and he says no
and the explanation is uh seems like
something out of a Dr Seuss novel
any of the mothers of your children
no to ask why why not uh why'd I need to
well because according to the article
one of the woman who says that you paid
for her to have an abortion is also the
mother of one of your children it seems
like that's that's an easy way he calls
out the article I have more kids okay he
says because of the article I had more
kids
what does that mean I don't know an
article forced him to have a child
somewhere the article impregnated
someone with his DNA what does that mean
because of the article I had more kids
that's why I reached out to anyone
because I said no and that's what I mean
when I said no I said it's not correct
that's a lie and that's what I mean
that's a lie
thank you that if this did happen
there's nothing to be ashamed of how do
you think this morning
he did say that and I'll have the clip
so first of all he's told you said this
morning in an interview if this did
happen it's nothing to be ashamed of him
he's like I never said that he did and
I'll play it for you in a moment
something totally different and if it
did happen I said but now it's my
ex-wife in my past nothing to do with
what this woman said I said this this
year the abortion thing is false it's a
lot and that's what I said I said
anything happened with my ex-wife or
what Christian was talking about I don't
know okay so he said I didn't say that
thing this morning and yet here he is
saying that thing yesterday morning that
it would be nothing to be ashamed of if
it were true I'm saying I've been
forgiven because of all the things I did
when I went to my when uh the thing with
my ex-wife and all that and things I did
I don't know how many years ago my book
as the guys I wasn't perfect
I had my problem with mental health
and I was uh I've uh I've been I I've
been I hate that I've been born again
but I have a new life and I've been
moving forward and and if that had
happened I would I would have said it
because there's nothing to be ashamed of
if that had happened I would have said
it because it's nothing to be ashamed of
there he is himself saying the thing and
not exactly sounding like a guy
who has his story straight that's for
damn sure and this is one of the worst
candidates not just this election cycle
this is one of the worst Senate
candidates I have ever seen quite
frankly he should be dropping out of the
race but he might win I mean the voters
in Georgia
are coming up with so many post-hoc
rationalizations for this he might
actually win we'll take a look at what
polling looks like after the weekend
here's another moment from this
disastrous press conference he's told
hey the lieutenant governor said the
only reason you're even in this thing is
because people know you from football
and he's like what's the what's that guy
doing now and they're like well he's the
lieutenant governor and he doesn't seem
to get it
lieutenant governor Jeff Duncan went on
TV I think last night and had some very
critical words of you saying that the
Republican party was in disarray I think
his directs both paraphrasing it was the
only reason these republican nominees
was because he scored a lot of
touchdowns for the University of Georgia
now who was it you said where did that
Jeff Duncan oh what is he doing now
[Laughter]
this is so insane what's that guy doing
is the lieutenant government he's like
you know but what is he doing no what is
he doing out here he's a details work
for who they only go on some TV channel
no no don't you go on the TV and talk a
lot
no no don't only go on TV and talk a lot
right now you know people like that do I
listen to you know people told me I
couldn't play football
listen that's true the lieutenant as far
as I know the lieutenant governor has
absolutely no no touchdowns to his name
that's uh that that's absolutely true
um
what's your reaction to people so close
to you saying you were dishonest like
his own son here's his answer to that
what's your reaction to people so close
to you your son a mother of your someone
who says it's you the mother of your
kids saying that you're lying once
you're actually people so close to you
saying don't trust you yeah just like
what I just said a Democrat is desperate
for this season the Democrats oh God his
son Christian Walker is a devout Maga
Republican this has nothing to do with
Democrats it's a I've never seen
anything like this who who advised them
to do this important they're very
desperate for the seat I love my family
I always love my family I'm going to win
this race I know I'm going to win this
race dear God what an absolute and total
disaster
um I am hopeful that by Monday or
Tuesday whenever we get the latest
polling on this race I'm hopeful that
um this will be essentially over now if
we look at the polling again we're still
waiting on new data we only have two
polls right now that include any polling
after the start of this Scandal and most
of these polls were still before the
Scandal but it represents about a four
point swing in the direction of Raphael
Warnock as you can see sort of before
this entire thing Scandal uh the the
this this Scandal before the Scandal
started
um you had them roughly tied and Warnock
has jumped out to a roughly four point
lead and you see the the red line there
is Walker if you're looking along with
me Walkers polling declining 95 of the
polling here is before the Scandal so
Monday Tuesday after the long weekend
hopefully we will have some new data in
which it looks much much worse for
Herschel Walker and again in a normal
country in a normal planet in a normal
Universe a Galaxy whatever this guy
would have no shot but this is not a
normal situation there's a new report
out which finds that young women are
trending liberal and that young men are
not trending more liberal the hill has a
piece 44 percent of young women counted
themselves liberal in 2021
compared to 25 percent of young men
according to Gallup the gender gap is
the largest recorded in 24 years of
polling the finding culminates years of
rising liberalism among women ages 18 to
29 with no increase in their male peers
the article notes quote several societal
forces have conspired to push young
women to the left including the metoo
movement former president Trump Rising
lgbtq identification and most recently
abortion policy slow cooking Trends in
marital status and educational
attainment have also nudged the needle
there's another aspect to this all of
that is true
there is a ton of nonsense about
masculinity
out there that I believe is impacting
the number of men willing to say that
they are on the left now I think some of
them are on the left but are unwilling
to say it but that's difficult to
actually prove so we can even keep it
outside of this discussion that's just
an opinion that I hold
um and it's it's based merely on
anecdotes I think there are some much
like for a time when you know lots of
times you hear there's more gay people
now than ever well are there more gay
people or is it that gay folks on
average are more open to saying that
that's how they identify whereas in the
past they were not for different
societal pressures I think right now
there is a societal pressure
particularly among without a doubt the
right wing and even among the center
where men have been convinced that there
is a lack of masculinity in Progressive
beliefs that there's a lack of
masculinity in to some degree empathy
you look at you look at silly little
things like the electric vehicle thing
we recently talked about Marjorie Taylor
green suggesting that Pete bootage's
supportive electric vehicles is somehow
um feminine that that it's emasculating
to for a man to drive an electric
vehicle and of course there it was
homophobic Buddha judge is gay and it
was all mixed up with this homophobia
that is
um just a a big thing for Marjorie
Taylor green
um you know thing also people to judge
being an involved Dad when Pete Buddha
judge and his Husband
um had twins Pete budage took paternity
leave and he was widely ridiculed by the
right Lauren bobert even saying what is
he chest feeding that's a quote is he
chest feeding and again the idea that
gay man paternity leave well it must be
somehow feminine well he's just being a
good dad that's all it is
um and so I I believe that that's a
factor as well and sadly
some of these sort of Guru type figures
that are predominantly appealing to
those on the right
um although Jordan Peterson appeals to
many on the left as well I'll be totally
upfront about that
although it may not be explicit from
Jordan Peterson
he puts together
a pretty clearly defined kind of
archetype for masculinity
that doesn't really include the types of
empathetic
sensitive Progressive beliefs and
perspectives that
um quite frankly have nothing to do with
masculinity so I think there's a lot
going on here and it is not surprising
that we see in terms of overt
identification young women identifying
more to the left
but not young men now then there's that
other X Factor and it's are some of
these young men actually Progressive but
they don't say it
because of that very same societal
pressure and I don't know the answer to
that I someone who knows more about
research methods might be able to say
well here's how you could study where
there is a sort of reticent
progressivism among some young men let
me know your thoughts I don't think this
is particularly good if I'm passing some
kind of a moral evaluation of it I don't
think it's a particularly good thing for
society let me know your thoughts find
me on Twitter at dpacman and if we get
some interesting feedback we'll do a
follow-up
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show is of course a
viewer and listener funded program we do
the bonus show every single day we have
a commercial free audio and video stream
of the show for our members and the way
you get it all get it all and get it
quickly and cheaply just the way uh
people love by signing up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code Obama
o-b-a-m-n-a That's Mike Nancy m-n-a to
get a sizable discount a discount nobody
should sneeze at
joinpakman.com is the place let's hear
from the most important people in the
world for the David packman show it is
our audience we take calls occasionally
via Discord you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and we're going to start today
with a very important person Mr Rogers
in Atlanta Georgia Mr Rogers welcome
what's on your mind today
hey uh Dave welcome to my neighborhood
um just wanted to ask
um I'm having difficulty I guess you'd
say uh reaching out to members uh would
say across the aisle about the Herschel
Walker and uh Warren Rock campaign okay
um I have a lot of neighbors that just
want to vote for vote for Herschel
because he was a damn good dog and uh I
mean as a native Georgian I understand
that and I get that but I'm like try to
talk to these guys about how you know
he's definitely not a good uh
representation of what it means to be a
Georgian or Southern Belle these days
and so let's help me understand that and
this is interesting because you're
you're talking to these folks Herschel
Walker is completely unable to explain
his position on even a single issue how
do these people that like him do do they
not even care what his positions are do
they pretend like they understand what
his positions are what how do they
explain his incoherence
um I mean I try to say like you know I
appreciate his time in football but his
tte just not what we need yeah
um when it comes to his positions
um they say you know it doesn't matter
you know he's just Republican he's just
gonna vote Republican I'm like y'all
worried about the uh Warnock being a
Biden boy and I'm like he's gonna as
soon as Walker gets there he's just
gonna be uh I don't know Moscow Mitch
it's a fair bit he's not gonna do
anything for majority he's just gonna be
told to vote and how to vote yeah I mean
it's obvious whenever you you uh you see
his um what he called news conferences
that Walker is about as coach as you can
get on some of his background kind of
yeah and still incoherent have you heard
from any folks about the reaction now to
the whole abortion Scandal do do they
care about this story or are they
calling it fake news or they don't care
um I have one guy I talked on a regular
he says it's fake news oh he just
doesn't believe yeah
uh another guy says you know he says
it's taken to court so we'll see how the
dollars fly and I don't know at least
you're willing to listen to the court
story and I haven't had much time to uh
talk to you that's really depressing
yeah let me ask you this are some of
these folks who support Walker are they
otherwise normal moderately intelligent
people or are there people who if you
probed their beliefs on just about
everything are a little bit wacky
um I'd say it's a mix of both because
you know you'd go down to the the bar
for a football game during commercials
you talk to people we'll talk normal
stuff but then all sudden but yeah it
can get a little odd sometimes but yeah
I'll be honest it seems like most of the
time Georgia fans just want to vote for
Herschel because he was named their dog
okay and what what do you mean a damn
good dog
oh I'm sorry David uh the college
football thing down here in the
southeast United States
um damn good dog is uh Georgia saying
for any good uh
particularly good football player Oh but
I'm so from I'm a damn good dog I'm a
graduate of the University of Georgia
myself but uh you get the damn good dog
uh I guess title if you really show how
just how good you are all right very
good is that a bike chain I hear in the
background
yeah I apologize for that my windows are
open it's a nice day today is that
January did I pick it it actually is a
bike chain
yeah oh wow all right that's it oh oh oh
I okay I thought it was like a bite all
right very good all right Mr Rogers
thank you let's let's hope Warnock wins
you know let's let's hope
indeed thank you all right thank you
very much for the call there's Mr Rogers
in Atlanta making a number of very very
important declarations there remember
anybody who wants to participate name
and location as your nickname if you
have only one or the other I will be
unable to call on you let's go uh next
to Noah from New York Noah from New York
welcome
hey David good to talk to you I'm uh
I've been watching you uh for a while so
a little nervous but thank you for
bringing me on well so far you're doing
great your audio is good so we're off to
a good start really
thank you I had I had to really look
around the settings figure out how to
turn off the Discord notifications good
uh anyway no I would say um I got a
question for you it's just a little more
of a silly question it's not too serious
because we can't really know it's like
you know what would you do in a zombie
apocalypse type stuff right
um I'm just curious I want to kick this
back and forth with you how do you think
um what's happening if climate change is
going to pan out we're not going to
clearly avoid it we're not doing nearly
enough uh what do you think the end
result of all this is going to be I mean
the damage what's what's going to happen
how it's going to affect our dialogue
and politics moving forward what do you
think it's so difficult to say and we're
so terrible at predicting things so let
me give you one claim that's made and
then I and which I don't believe and
then we'll back up from it there are
some who say listen I don't deny that
what climatologists have identified is
real and it's coming I just am confident
that science and engineering is going to
be able to keep up to prevent it from
ever really getting that bad okay that's
something some people say
I don't subscribe to that I don't
subscribe to that however I do think
that after there is a bunch of Damage
Done by climate change and we're already
starting to see it we see pollution
deaths we see sea level rising in
certain places increasingly underwater
like we're already seeing it but I think
after there is some significant damage
from climate change I think then much of
the world will kick it into high gear
and yes it'll be too little too late but
it will speed up to a degree that then
we can say now we're making some
progress but it'll be after a bunch of
damage is done that that's my genuine
prediction like once things really
actually start to get bad
yeah that's what I thought too is that
like you're not really going to see it
taken seriously until you get issues
with like a climate refugees and mass
migration to a lot of you know what we
call First World countries or damage
there that and the thing is a lot of
people are going to hear our
conversation Noah and they'll say but
guys that's already happening and I
don't deny that but I'm saying it's
going to have to be more it's gonna have
to be more yeah it's going to be massive
yeah I think do you think you're going
to see like um almost some crackdowns on
like those who have opposed or do a pose
it and uh and generally do you think
like like I'm talking like authoritarian
situation because I do Wonder this like
if things get very bad and desperate are
you gonna see like hard-line measures
taken by governments that are going to
cause like pushback and stuff absolutely
there are countries that already lean
more authoritarian the countries that
lean more authoritarian whenever we get
to this imaginary point that I'm talking
about I think you will see some very
hard line action by some governments uh
but you will have to wait and see
exactly what governments which
governments those are at that time
yeah and how they'll go all right and
one last thing um do you think people
who are like hardcore denying it are
ever going to come around or do you
think there's probably still going to be
like a block that are just going to
convince themselves that it's like
antifa changing the weather yeah there
will always be people who who believe
it's gen geoengineering or something
like that
all right listen before I let you go can
you off the off your the top of your
head can you name four countries that
start with the letter L
um let's say
Lithuania uh yeah man you're putting me
on the spot here so now it's like it's
like when people are asked to name a
book yeah they're like name any book and
they're like oh God which books are so
many I mean Lithuania
Liechtenstein I would have also accepted
Luxembourg Latvia and Laos yeah
there we go yeah yeah that's all right
Noah thank you for the call appreciate
it all right you too take care take care
there's Noah from New York uh bringing
up some sad but relevant and important
issues I have to say let's go next to
Chuck from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Chuck
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
what's going on David can you hear me I
can
uh not really a question just kind of uh
giving you guys an update from uh PA
here since yeah
this uh important Senate race coming up
here yeah
yeah yeah well so um yeah I live uh I
don't actually live in Pittsburgh I live
south of Pittsburgh about an hour but it
looks like really the only notable thing
uh so that's why I put that but I live
in Fayette County and it's pretty pretty
rad here
um
but I mean it's just it's pretty
disgusting when I drive around like
um everybody's got all these uh
mastriano signs in there so it's got me
a little worried the only thing I you
guys or you cover like the uh the
polling yeah it's looking pretty good
right now for Shapiro
yeah it's looking good so that's that's
got my hopes up um I know that like when
I drive around like I said it gets me uh
a little worried just because you know I
live in like a red area so that's all I
see yeah
um but uh another thing uh I was at the
Washington County Fair which is actually
the county to the left of me
um and did we say to the West is that
what you mean uh yeah to the west or
left if you were like looking on a map
okay I didn't know if you meant like
left the way you're sitting right now or
something like that oh no okay
um
uh but um as we were leaving the fair
and again I'm not a big Fair person I
just kind of went because I don't know I
haven't been in a while and uh we were
leaving and we're walking back to
through this like field to our car and
like the this family is walking out and
they got like three kids and they're all
I can't remember if they were I think
they were just waving either American
flags or uh like Doug mastriano Flags or
something but their kids were chanting
fjb and it was just like a very very
disturbing sight to see like how old
were the kids I oh probably like nine
eight oh my goodness yeah it was like
very cultish
um but I it was pretty disgusting and
then another thing real quick is like
where I live I actually fly
an American flag off my house just to
kind of because like I feel like a lot
of Republican like you know if you're
not a Trumper if you don't support the
us or like if you don't fly a U.S flag I
feel like you're like looked at as like
a demon it's thinking Republican yeah so
yeah just trying to flag off my house to
maybe you know not get my house shot up
or something by an angry Republican
that's not bad I mean you know the the
Eggman who's a Jewish Progressive but
lives in Upstate New York he wears
flannels and grows a big beard to try to
blend in so I understand
yeah I grow a beer I don't grow a beard
for that reason
um I actually just enjoy a beard but
yeah
um it actually does help uh fit in I
guess a little bit it certainly does all
right my friend thank you so much for
the call I appreciate it
yep no worries all right uh the
interesting calls today from all over
the place I'm uh I'm I'm liking it uh
let's see where do we want to go next
how about uh let's go to lahav from
Greensboro lahav welcome to the program
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
fine
okay I want to play a quick Fire game
we're gonna play a game now you and I
yes okay I list a politician and I want
you to say the first word you think of
to describe them okay let's try it
Elizabeth Warren
oh boy
uh buttoned up
uh Kirsten Cinema
confused
foreign
vicious
Jamal Bowman
don't know enough about him to really
comment with one word
um Mitt Romney
um
timid
um let's see
Steve scalise
uh pathetic
um Gretchen Whitmer
oh man Gresham at work uh milk toast
um
AOC
passionate
Jill Stein
um very nice I guess
Jeb Bush
um do you have Bush very nice how many
more of these are there by the way oh
I'm sorry did you see Jill Stein I
thought you said Jill Biden hold on Jill
Stein Jill Stein uh cuckoo
yeah that's better okay Tulsi gabbard uh
despicable
okay and um
let's see here let's stop let's leave it
there I think that's good that's a lot I
don't know that I have too many of these
left in me
okay thank you all right thank you very
much for the call appreciate it uh by
the way milk toast is
m-i-l-q-u-e for everybody who now is
looking that up but it's not it's not
like milk milk like from cereal and milk
all right everybody let's take a very
quick break but we're still going to
take calls after the break so if you're
holding to chat with me hold on just a
little longer and I will hopefully get
to you quick break
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's hear from a few more people in our
audience we take calls weekly via
Discord you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord that is the place to go
let's try JoJo from Melbourne Australia
which can sometimes go well sometimes
JoJo's calls get a little risque JoJo
what's on your mind today
uh oh yeah
um
Jojo
hello hello JoJo did you have a question
for me today oh yeah are you can you
hear me yes
hi hi David uh I do have a question for
you yes um
uh okay I'm going to talk about ineptism
did you see the uh wave of it coming uh
did you think it was abnormal
um so obviously first of all there was
the
family that took over the White House
and then
there's uh Clarence Thomas and his wife
um this is nothing like
I would have seen in my country anyway
but is did you think there was a
abnormal or was it just something that
I seem to be beneficial in the Trump
Administration was particularly Brazen
but not altogether surprising
yeah I mean I thought it was in
particular but then it just capped it
off with the Judy Thomas and uh Clarence
Thomas theme which I think I mean in a
normal
world I would think that he would uh
resign his place in the Supreme Court
but that's just me I'm not sure yeah I
don't know what the Clarence Thomas
thing is necessarily nepotism I think
it's more uh corruption you know and uh
yeah I don't know that nepotism is the
word I would apply but it's certainly
disgusting that's for sure
oh absolutely well Netflix are not not
necessarily but um a what do you call it
um
what is it uh
well it's certainly corruption it's out
of trading I don't know are you
interested in a trivia question can I
give you a trivia question
absolutely can you name countries that
start with the letter j
um countries uh
oh my God you put me in the spot
um
uh
can you give me another letter well
that's the letter I have JoJo listen
I've got a whole bunch of people here I
do have to move on
Johannesburg is a city Johannesburg is a
city no I know it is I know I'm really
good at um geography please give me
another letter one that's the only
letter I have Jojo I have to let you go
I apologize
um all right JoJo okay here he is JoJo
from Melbourne Australia very much
appreciate it would have accepted Japan
would have accepted Jamaica and would
have accepted Jordan as well all would
have been acceptable let's go to Shelley
from Indiana Shelly welcome to the
program what can I do for you today
I'm doing well
okay great uh uh so I
don't know the governmental programs and
how we have
so many people that disapprove of them
and I was wondering if the left maybe
took more
um the approach of what the swedens do
where they offer programs to everyone no
matter the no matter what the income
level is that way more people would be
on board with it and that it would help
more people you're saying eliminate
means testing and then maybe there would
be less opposition to social welfare
programs in the United States if
everybody just got them
right exactly so obviously there would
be like people on the lower and would
get more benefits but if if the people
that made more money felt like they were
still getting something out of it then
it wouldn't be the one paying into it
and I'm not getting anything from it I
totally understand the idea
I don't think it would make a big
difference to many Republicans
unfortunately I think with some it would
but I think with many it would not
well and the reason why
why I thought that it might be a good
idea is because when when they were
doing the stimulus checks and there was
more you know people on the higher end
that were still getting you saw people
that that weren't really wouldn't
normally approve of those programs right
I'm happy to get it and so it's like
well maybe if we expanded this where
people felt like they were still getting
something out of it yeah
I don't know it was just the thought
it's an idea I think it would do a
little I don't think it would make a big
difference that's my instinct
yeah how are things in Indiana things
are okay there you're you're welcoming
back Mike Pence and everything
uh I'm sure they uh but uh the weather
is really good so that's good yeah good
Shelly I appreciate the call
all right thank you so much so much all
right Shelly from Indiana always great
to hear from her let's go to Lucas from
Brazil Brazil of course we'll have a
runoff election on October 30th and
things are quite wild there Lucas what's
going on
hello do you listen I can hear you
so I want to ask you about a video you
made two months ago about Christina
kishni as a snatch my team do you
remember the video I do
well it's kind of a hard question let's
see don't you think it was a bit
conspiratorial the video
yes I admit that in the video
I mean even the right wing media in
Brazil they hate Argentina they think
it's like far left or whatever they will
insane that I mean it seems like you did
some Clinton Body Count but the
Christian body yeah listen I mean I say
in the video uh it could absolutely be
perceived that way it's it's just you
know I I'm not pointing fingers to
anyone in particular just the entire
thing stinks to high heaven and uh I I
it's certainly not a unique you know
Argentinian media have have suggested it
and uh yeah but I I say in the video
it's conspiratorial without a doubt
the problem with breaking news uh
breaking news media coverage in general
you don't have Auto information and so
on for example I I it didn't have
anything to do with it being breaking I
still have the same opinion today I mean
and now it's you know it's been two
months so I don't know
but you still think that it was kind of
a fake flag today or I think it's
completely plausible this is one of the
most corrupt people in the history of
Argentinian Politics on the cusp of very
serious evidence being presented against
her and I would put nothing past her
morally for sure
okay so I guess you just a bit bite the
bullet on the conspiratory stuff I guess
I'm biting the bullet yep the frogs are
turning gay and everything you got me no
problem no problem uh one little
question about rankings Choice voting do
you think it's a good path forward or I
mean what do you have any take on it yes
I have a dozen videos about this where I
including go through the different forms
of it single transferable vote and
others and generally speaking some
version of ranked Choice voting is very
appealing to me
I see oh well I guess that was my
questions thank you David all right
Lucas thank you and who do you support
in the upcoming election by the way
um in the second round rule about in the
first uh a politician named Zero Gomez
that didn't go very well okay fair
enough but Lula in this all right well
we're going to be watching it closely my
friend
good good thank you there's Lucas from
Brazil with a very very important
election upcoming let's go to Grant from
Iowa City Grant welcome to the program
hey David
um so I know you get a lot of criticism
and stuff obviously from people way on
the on the right side of you yeah and
the left on the Spectrum and oh yeah the
left two deaths is going to say so for
when you get criticism from people left
of you
um for me personally I like it just
gives me like a ton of anxiety I get
nervous about it because I I am afraid
of being like perceived as like this you
know negative whatever a Negative Nancy
we're not supposed to use Negative Nancy
anymore
I'm not sure yeah I don't know either
like even stuff like that I guess like
hearing that I would be like oh gosh
like you know I know please don't think
I'm a bad person
um you know I ate an egg please don't
kill me
yeah
um so I guess how do you kind of
personally
um
handle uh you know getting criticism
from people left to be who would say you
know you're either you're a horrible
person for what you believe or whatever
because for me it just kind of naturally
wanted to live that peace of like
everybody it just like yeah I don't know
it really bends me out of shape well
here's the thing a lot of this stuff in
person
would not become what it is when you're
leaving someone a voicemail or leaving a
comment on their videos people are just
by their nature much more
confrontational online and so I see you
know these people who attack me from the
left but we agree on like 95 of stuff I
don't get too bent out of shape about it
quite frankly I don't really pay much
attention to any of it I just kind of do
my thing and and try to focus on what
I'm doing and learn and read as much as
I can and modify My Views when I feel
that uh the facts point me in a New
Direction and I try to screen out as
much of the noise as possible left and
right
right right yeah I'm sure that's
absolutely necessary for you as well
like you know having such a uh you know
a lot of uh encounters with so many
people
um I could not do what you do definitely
don't say that much absolutely
but uh yeah I know I was just wondering
and uh has it gotten easier for you like
as you get older too
um just like is it easier to screen out
the negative noise absolutely and not
take that so seriously absolutely
without a doubt yeah no doubt about it I
mean at the beginning it was like one
negative comment which was by the way we
only would get one comment a day and it
was like a really big deal but yeah it
definitely becomes easier
yeah yeah
um no I'm just curious because it's like
I'm thinking like I'm way behind on this
stuff because
um I'm almost 26 now and I'm like I feel
like I get bent out of shape as if I'm a
seven-year-old or something yeah I mean
I think part of it is one of the things
is really understanding that for a lot
of these people that are so willing and
eager to criticize others
they probably don't feel that great
about themselves and often attacks on
others are more a reflection of the
attackers either low self-esteem or
trials or tribulations and once I
started thinking that like wow this
person must really have some horrible
stuff going on to be spending an hour on
the internet leaving me a hundred
negative comments I I kind of feel bad
for them more than anything else
yeah yeah that makes sense
um yeah sorry my question wasn't a
political one or whatever no that's okay
do you want a trivia question before you
go
oh gosh uh you can try I'm gonna totally
watch it because I'm quite nervous but
okay we can go for it I guess what what
is the typical name for a dried plum
when you buy it as a dried fruit what do
they call a dried plum
um a prune you're absolutely correct
all right my friend thank you for the
call I appreciate it yeah thanks David
all right take care uh there's Grant
from Iowa City really excellent
excellent execution there on the um on
the trivia trivia question that could
have gone bad it could have gone very
bad and thankfully it did not let's go
to Summer from Metro somewhere I can't
see it's met where are you calling from
Samir
so mayor left okay so mayor apparently
did not want to be on that's uh that's
interesting let's go to instead Garrett
from Chicago Garrett welcome to the
program
hello Mr David the Pac-Man sir
uh welcome thank you
um I my question is about
um
uh like the popularity of candidates uh
when affecting other people that are
running in the same election I worded
that poorly okay uh just to give you an
example uh in Georgia the uh Brian Kemp
is currently leading six or seven points
in most of the polls okay uh and he's a
republican obviously whereas uh Warnock
is currently up anywhere from three to
five
um what I saw is Warnock is up 1.3
1.3 okay well
um I'm I'm just I have 538 pulled up the
most recent polls but yeah
um so uh
my question is will the will the
popularity of Warnock or the on of
Warnock or Kemp affect the uh do you
think it'll affect the turnout of the
other side like do you think Kemp's
popularity will improve uh Walker's
chances or do you think warnock's chant
or warnock's popularity will improve
Stacey Abrams chances oh I that is so
specific I have no idea listen turn out
in midterms predicting turnout in
midterms is very fraught and difficult
and every election cycle is oh turnout's
gonna win it for this person or that
person and it's so difficult to predict
and your question is even more specific
which is whatever base level of turnout
is to be expected will one candidate's
popularity buoy or sync another can I
just have no idea I think all we can do
right now we're a month out it's
basically four and a half weeks or
something until the election roughly is
make sure you're registered make sure
you know where to vote and make sure to
vote that's it and I think all of these
calculations they're interesting
questions we're going to know in
retrospect only once we get exit poll
data I don't know we we've just really
got to make sure not to lose any of
these winnable races
uh thank you very much Mr David the
Pac-Man sir do you want a trivia
question before you go of course what's
the most expensive spice by weight and
when we say spice we're talking about
cooking what's the most expensive spice
by weight
so not the spice from Dune no no no no
um
oh geez probably
uh
um I'm gonna say
I can only name like three spices I'm
gonna say time no no time is cheap oh my
God it's almost a weed it's almost
invasive the answer is saffron it's
saffron
oh yes of course yeah yeah all right
very good thank you for the call
thank you sir all right I really
appreciate everybody who called in and
spoke to me I even appreciate people who
called in and didn't speak to me the
people who didn't call in I'm not so big
on you folks but uh no in all
seriousness we will take calls again
we're gonna take a quick break and we
will be back with more show right after
this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the Friday
mailbag info davidpackman.com for
questions comments concerns suggestions
all of it and of course occasionally a
tweet or a Facebook message or a YouTube
comment might make it into this segment
we love all of it let's start today with
some criticisms some criticisms which I
am I'm glad to issue Corrections when I
make mistakes I'm glad to give a
sampling of comments from people that
aren't thrilled with me uh David wrote
in and said you were out there dude
Trump was and maybe will be again the
best thing that's happened to this
country in decades open your eyes your
radio cast must be funded by the demo
rats no the demo rats and the demon rats
and the Democrats none of them fund the
show George Soros doesn't fund the show
whoever else you imagine is funding the
show doesn't fund the show the show's
funded mostly by our audience and then
by a few advertisers that's that's kind
of what it is
um the uh I guess all I can say is
congratulations for using the correct
your the correct form of your all right
so David is waiting around for the
return of trump almost uh in like a
weird Messianic way it's very very
interesting next criticism is from Don
Don wrote in and said you are a freaking
idiot take your liberal Marxist
socialistic garbage somewhere else it's
idiots like you that are destroying this
country the oligarchies are bringing
this that's oligarchy apostrophe s are
bringing this country down and should
they succeed you won't mean crap to them
then let's see how you will put food on
your table pay your mortgage and charge
your defunct grid system car you don't
know crap and are just as stupid as the
rest of your Democratic constituents
well a really strong condemnation
uh by dawn of a political ideology that
I don't hold I I'm not a Marxist or a
socialist but maybe go find a Marxist or
a socialist and criticize them I don't
know it's always weird they seem
confused uh Matt wrote in about
interviews with the so-called radical
left Matt says David sir just listen to
your explanation of how right-wing
candidates may or may not end up on your
show for interviews and it made me
wonder if there are any left-wing
candidates that you might consider
radical or unreasonable in some of their
views and if you'd be interested in
interviewing them perhaps there aren't
any and it is purely a disease of the
Republican party I wouldn't be surprised
but I'd be interested in your take
either way yeah I mean listen there are
extreme leftists the the difference is
the extreme leftists don't ever seem to
win their Democratic primaries and one
of the things we do on this show because
we can't turn the show into the you know
ninth congressional district show where
we interview everybody running for the
Democratic nomination and everybody
running for the Republican nomination we
tend to wait until after primaries to do
these interviews as a practical matter
and the Republicans will often vote for
the wackiest in the primary and so
that's who I end up interviewing
Democrats rarely vote for the super
wacky extreme left Winger
um and so by the time they get to me
there's been a sorting already and much
the same way that Trump would never have
won the Democratic Primary in 2016. a
lot of the so-called radical left that
Matt is referring to in his email don't
pass that first filter and that's why
they don't end up on the show but I have
no opposition in principle to speaking
to anybody uh Robert Rhoden this is very
interesting and this relates to Roe v
Wade and abortion and other things we've
been talking about Robert says big fan
of the show appreciate your rational
approach to controversial subjects
wanted to write to you about abortion
people are unfortunately but legally
making end-of-life decisions all the
time when an individual's higher brain
function ceases the family can opt to
have life support suspended this is
generally rationalized by the collective
understanding that once higher brain
functions have ended the person is
already gone if people have accepted and
this is the wrong accepted okay so the
the right word here is ACC this is the
but let's imagine we understand what
Robert is saying if people have accepted
that this is the way things are then why
can't the opposite be true if your life
ends when your higher brain function
stops then why would your beginning of
Life be before your higher brain
function begins my understanding is that
dreaming is supposed to begin in the
third trimester if I'm not mistaken this
should signify the beginnings of thought
and the brains need to process them so
there's a couple issues here first of
all Robert is completely correct and
there's actually another aspect to this
which is
quote other people
make decisions about end of life all the
time as you're talking about in
situations where people's brain function
has stopped or in lots of different
situations including hospice type
situations why couldn't the same
decisions be made when a fetus has no
brain function and isn't going to so in
these most extreme cases where
Republicans want women carrying
non-viable fetuses to term why is it
okay to make those decisions for others
later and not earlier aside from the
personhood question but there's kind of
a bigger issue here which is you're
never going to convince the right on
abortion with arguments like this
because they will say well we don't care
about brain function we care about
heartbeat and that's where the heartbeat
bills come from and then you'd say well
okay but what about this and they'll say
now We Believe life begins at conception
and it's an endless loop and so while
these types of questions that Robert
brings up are super interesting and
they're accurate and they're relevant
that's not going to convince the most
Ardent anti-choicers on the right sadly
I wish we could talk sense with them but
unfortunately we can't Sean wrote in
about my interview with that Republican
candidate Allison Hayden who's running
against our friend Eric swalwell and
Sean says to David whoever whomever I
enjoy all of David's interviews I find
them fascinating and informative but I
think my favorite type of interview is
when David speaks to Republicans who
seem to be confused by facts versus
their opinion needless to say I was
glued to your discussion with Allison
Hayden as per the usual I think David
did a great job but there's one question
I would love to hear him ask of these
people if Trump would have won the
presidency would they still be making
such a big deal out of the legitimacy
and security of our elections guys we
all know the answer to that of course
they wouldn't
if Trump had won
the electoral vote or the electoral vote
and the popular vote they would be doing
what they did in 2016 which is saying
sort of like there was some fraud
and my real victory was even bigger but
they would not be filing 60 70 Court
complaints of course they wouldn't be
doing any of those things don't believe
for a second that this is some kind of
moral fight for them it's just about
their guy lost that's all they care
about
Daniel wrote in about my Republican
guests and says David after hearing your
interview yesterday with the Northern
California Republican candidate that was
Allison Hayden and after hearing several
other recent videos interviews I have an
honest inquiry as to whether you seek
out the worst Republican candidates to
interview or if you're just shooting
fish in a barrel do you specifically
Target The Crazies or are you just
giving us a sampling of what the
Republican party has generally become
love you're taking them to task though
and trying desperately to make them
think about the word salad they're
spewing so last week we had a voicemail
asking a similar question my colleague
John has been heading up these
interviews he has interviewed I want to
say close to 50 different Republican
candidates some of them don't even
respond some of them do but then they
find out about how interviews are
conducted here and that real questions
will be asked and then they say I'm not
interested or they stop responding some
will agree to come on and then once we
schedule it we'll never hear from them
again some confirm the interview
literally hours before it's scheduled
and then they just never show up on
Skype and we never hear from them again
we cast a wide net
some of them are less crazy like that
guy Johnny T guy interviewed I still
disagree with him about just about
everything but he was less overtly
Bonkers and less cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
but we are casting a wide net we're not
targeting the whack jobs but a lot of
them are really wacky and it's just a
representation of who's running in that
party right now
um I the zombie plail
wrote in and said David you should sit
back and think about why right Wingers
around the world are performing better
than ever people are very angry at their
politicians yeah it's I think the
implication here is the left has done so
terribly that globally and really they
mean like Western Europe and to some
degree but the Americas voters are going
to right Wingers
what's going on is that
parties on both sides anecdotally have
failed voters in lots of parts of the
world but the real change has been
the echo Chambers created by social
media and modern media which allow
really
stupid quite frankly ideas primarily on
the non-science right to get repetition
that they wouldn't otherwise get we've
talked before if Nixon had had Fox News
and Facebook
it's not clear Nixon would have actually
ended up resigning and it's possible he
would have been impeached by the house
and maybe not convicted by the Senate if
Senators at the time had seen support in
social media the way there was support
for Trump during the impeachment trials
that he had so I do think that a lot of
this is thanks to disinformation
uh faux populist messages or maybe
actual populist messages which don't
really lead to any substantive policy
have also kind of infected the political
discussion and so it's not about the
left has been so bad that right-wingers
have won that's it's not that at all but
there is a story there to be told and I
think it's an important one for sure
uh all right if you have any questions
comments concerns things you want to say
write to info
davidpackman.com your email may be
featured on an upcoming episode and
remember that the party doesn't have to
end right now you can sign up on my
website joinpakman.com to get an extra
show every day that's the bonus show and
so many more great member benefits you
can use the coupon code indict i n d i c
t to save a bundle off of the cost of a
membership we'll see you on the bonus
show or otherwise back here on Monday
foreign